[Musique]
j'apprécie le fait que aussi bien madame
le pen que monsieur mélenchon estime
qu'un citoyen français doit être défendu
quoi qu'il arrive et que le non respect
des droits de l'homme doit être aussi à
que je dirais quelques pas accusés
doivent être mises en relève et je pense
que dans le cas du japon la foison
d'hier m'ont traitée est une façon qui
n'est pas digne d'une nation qui a signé
le traité de respect des droits de
l'homme c'est que cette inertie
française est ce que vous pensez que les
autorités donnent le là finalement
oscars ou gilet jaune qui sont en guerre
dont elle franchement je pense que
quelque part quand vous êtes quand vous
êtes patron en france
vous êtes déjà un peu un pari à quoi un
appareil à privilégier vous êtes un
parieur qui est le patron est un mal
nécessaire
on sait par faire sans les patrons si on
pouvait se passer des patrons je pense
qu'on l'aurait déjà fait depuis
longtemps
on peut pas être passé et donc c'est des
gens qui sont mal aimés et donc vous
devenez un parieur moi je demande à être
au-dessus des eaux dessus des lois mais
je demande pas réussir je ne peux pas
accepter d'être en dessous des voix ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on me traite
comme un citoyen comme les autres
je pense que ce que madame le pen a dit
d'à côté est ce que monsieur mélenchon
on dit de l'autre côté c'est exactement
ça un français est un français qui ne
veut pas être au dessus de la loi et
peut pas être totalement
[Musique]